ora mi ridai lo sai benvenuti solite
stories in questo video divertente petri
e mostre me di trucchetti per nascondere
lo slime a scuola io sono in italia
vitale e oggi andiamo farvi vedere dei
trucchetti per nascondere lo slime a
scuola e come credo che andiamo a
utilizzare e il corredo di skin over
infatti sono questi zaini benissimo che
sono in due edizioni perché edizioni
normale con le spalline di essere gioco
prendiamo su diversi e vitale e io sono
sales e rosa e verde e nero celeste blu
e verde fosforescente
questa è anche la selezione con le ruote
che è fantastica malgrati può
trasportare così con le ruote non vi
pesano i libri se dovete trasportarne
tanti e se anche la maniglia che si
possa dare anche per andare in viaggio e
fa totti che oggi slime è infatti chiusa
confezionamento fossero utilizzate
sembra strano ma vero
pesano tantissimo età che in fasi con
nascondere di slam sono l'ideale
cioccolato
dai tasti di questo zaino prima kakà 5
tutto possiamo fare tantissimi di sly
mutua boys e una seconda tasca seconda
tasca principale per questo che le norme
ci sono gli astucci abbinati sono tutti
come abbiamo detto e questo tre sezioni
c'è un altro sezione ancora in cui si
possono mettere altri league sono made
in china punto piu nero per chiudersi
anche un'altra tasca in cui si possono
mettere le cuffie per ascoltare la
musica sacco di cose le mandate indiano
ascoltare la musica di nascosto super
anche a v secolo
allora sei colonne grazie a delle altre
macchine sconosciuto denuncia cose buone
altre tappe super ampia e tra l'altro
qua si può chiudere la cerniera ma poi
dietro è chiuso ma se volete si può
aprire fermo già esistono le spalline
che si possono attaccare quel tesoro
proprio che multifunzionale fantastico
che beppe viola innovativo nella prima
sezione abbiamo due penne cancellabili
roy dal gruppo amici matita temperino
comunemente l'albero
se tutto quello di cui avete bisogno del
comando di un porti mezzo e pastelli
sono bellissimi sopra accesi questi
colori scompartimento ci sono tantissimi
pennarelli stati fantastici zani ci
aiuteranno sicuramente a nascondere il
nucleare ma dissi mi lanciai un
paravento perché sono sempre spaziosi
tutto nonché leggerissimi
non riusciva a pescarsi o non ci
riuscirà scrivetemi saperlo
basti vedere come si fosse stati
preferiti di più il mio rosa celeste è
chiaro che mesi fantastici prodotti sti
9 potete trovarli solo nelle migliori
cartolerie italiane e potete anche o
cliccare sul link in descrizione per
vedere meglio tutti i prodotti prima di
nascondere lo slime dobbiamo prima fare
lo slide come in questo zaino esistono
tantissime cose perché il super spazioso
siamo riusciti a trasportare tutto non
può che cosa sono riuscito a trasfondere
io qua dentro intero di con una tanica
di gomma bianca spetta perché io riesco
trasportare tutt'altra piotta sarà
l'ideale si vuole ha detto la soluzione
per letti
no per ora no il colorante
stiamo urlando dobbiamo presente prima
che riteniamo che lo nascondo la colla
festa per fortuna l'insegnante non è
ancora un ribasso quindi abbiamo tempo
per fare lottare ha scelto un bellissimo
ragazzo sta diventato fucsia sta
diventando rosso in realtà un po ma poi
nella tasca segreta verso la luce c'è
qualcos'altro
entriamo il giro tutto 2 spatola nel
frattempo per essere più veloce è già
bellissimo
e allora cosa simone parti torno e vero
corato e poi andiamo metterli tutti e
due
così vediamo se riusciamo ad attivarlo
prima che lo sciopero vignette di
gelatina gerini finché gazzettino in
certi temi campionato non è arrivato per
fortuna poi appena arriva l'insegnate
l'abbiamo dato però ce l'ho fatta e
pronto portate che brucia
ho sentito che sta arrivando
l'insegnante è sì è il mio l'ho fatto io
cambia molino spadoni 0 io ho preso
questo io credo presente e allora se
abbiamo sì di poco giusto ora mi ridai
lo sai se le mani dai 20 ai ragazzi ben
tornati in a day giorno salve prof
vi ricordo le regole della scuola non si
mastica la gomma non si parla con il
compagno e soprattutto niente drive
un'idea
[Musica]
ho nuovamente sentito un rumore di slime
vi ricordo che gli slaves ok pro prio
trucchetto per il primo trucchetto
nasconderemo lo slime nel temperamatite
prendete il vostro temperamatite
prendete lo slime è infilatelo
lentamente mary temperamatite in questo
modo si nasconderà bene e per tirarlo
fuori
potete mettere la penna dentro e tirarlo
fuori in questo modo così potrete
giocare con lo slime di nascosto in
classe senza che nessuno se ne accorga
[Musica]
secondo trucchetto nascondere lo slime
in una penna rossa in questo caso lo
slime al rosso quindi viene ancora
meglio
prendete la vostra penna rossa o plus e
lo saremo blu potete infilare le stai un
nel tappo della penna piano piano poi
richiedete la penna ogni volta che
riaprirete la penna uscirà fuori il
vostro slime nascosto potete anche
sorprendere i vostri compagni
soprattutto quelli che mi chiedono
sempre in prestito le penne un rumore
viaggio pro che rumore di slime dovevano
sentito niente
terzo trucchetto questo è il mio
trucchetto preferito perché è davvero
fantastico e cioè come nascondere lo
slime in un quaderno guardate quanto
snai ma ci sta è davvero fantastico
questo trucchetto è il quaderno si può
richiudere così si può nascondere bene
lo slime scrivete nei commenti qual è il
vostro colore preferito di slime è mio
e questo il céleste per nascondere lo
slime nel quaderno prendete un quaderno
prendete il righello e con un taglierino
se siete piccolini fatevi aiutare da un
adulto
ritagliate un quadrato al centro del
quaderno il quadrato deve essere molto
profondo perché si deve stare un bel po
di slime dentro
una volta ritagliata togliete i fogli se
non è profondo abbastanza potete
continuare a intagliare i fogli ea
togliere la parte quadrato dei fogli da
ecco il nostro nascondiglio per il
nostro slime ora non vi resta che è
posizionare slime nel quaderno fatelo
aderire bene ai bordi del quadrato
potete anche il richiudere il quaderno e
non si vedrà
[Musica]
buongiorno 9 state sono il supplente
allora vediamo un po vediamo un po
facciamo appello line proibiti cos'è
questo cosa sono gli steela i propri
center o una cosa fantastica quali
abbiamo nascosto ordine ecco qua
guardi che bello questo è un host line
quindi interessante quindi questi sono
proibiti
giusto quindi se sono proibiti si no
l'ho detto io e mi dispiace
c'è scritto qui sly proibiti quindi
requisito basta non si deve usare solo
proibiti
fine lo slime è piaciuto così tanto
all'insegnante che ho deciso di
sequestrarlo verso le corse scritto mesi
nei commenti qual è il trucchetto che vi
ha divertito più di tutti siamo
divertiti un sacco e soprattutto gli
zaini e suggestivo per sono stati super
comodi per questo video si rivediamo che
potete trovarli tutti solo delle
migliori cartolerie italiane ed elin che
in descrizione andate cliccare qui
potete vederli tutti sono veramente
fantastici e li utilizzeremo per i
nostri viaggi per andare in giro sono
stupido scuola
fate un bel mi piace se volete vedere
altri video slime e trucchetti allora mi
lasciavo fa quattro cartellini e su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella preferita e vuole
missione